I've been sent another maximization or
minimization problem and and this seemed
to be an interesting twist on what we've
already done so let's do this one let's
see a rectangular storage container with
an open top is to have a volume of 10
meters cubed the length of its base is
twice its width so let me start drawing
this thing it's a rectangular storage
container with an open top so let's see
let me do it in a different color do it
in this color
okay so I'll do it over here so that's
its base so let's see the length of its
base is twice its width so this is the
base and if I call this the width so
this is X the length is twice that this
is 2x right the length of its base is
twice the width right so this is the
length of the base this is the width
okay
material and then the height the height
for now is unknown I think we should be
able to find a constraint on this
because we know what the volume has to
be right and says material for the sides
for the sides cost six dollars per
square meter find the cost of materials
for the cheapest such container okay so
let's do a couple of things first let's
figure out what the height is in terms
of X and then we can find an equation
for the cost in terms of X and then take
the derivatives and find the minimum mix
that are et cetera so what do we know
about this what's the volume of this box
the volume of this box is equal to the
what is it what did I say this this is
the the length but doesn't really matter
length times the width times the height
so it's 2x times X 2x squared times H so
it's 2x squared times H right base times
height times width or whatever length
times width times height just the volume
of a container of a rectangle and they
already said that the volume is 10
meters cubed so that gives us a good
constraint so that has to equal 10
alright let's divide both sides by by
two x squared and so what do we get if
we take this equation we divide both
sides by two x squared we get H is equal
to 10 over 2 x squared which is equal to
we could say 5 X to the minus 2 power so
this is so we could write this as 5 X to
the minus 2 power that is H we've just
solved that we were able to solve that
because they gave us a constraint on the
volume of the box fair enough
so let's see what the cost of the
material the total cost of the material
is going to be so I'll do that in
magenta the cost of the material and I
could even say as a function of X is
equal to what okay material for the
sides cost six dollars per square meter
so what is what is the surface area of
the sides I don't know they tell us the
material for the base first so material
for the base cost ten dollars per square
meter so this base right here the
material cost ten dollars per square
meter so what is the cost of the base
it's going to be the area of the base
times ten so it's ten times the area of
the base what's the area of the base
it's 2x times X so it's 2x squared so
this is the cost of the material on the
base and now we want to add the cost of
the material on the sides so now this
this is where gets a little bit
interesting so there's there's so
there's two sides that are X that these
this side and this side are the same
size right and so what are they what are
their areas there so it's going to be
six dollars per square meter for those
two sides right for this green side and
that one back there as well I don't want
to make this too messy so six dollars
and what's the area and there's two of
these sides I'm going to multiply by two
and so what's the area of each of these
sides
it's x times 5x minus 2 so that's 5x
minus 1 all right so now we have to
figure out this side here and that side
over there and let me do it in a brown
maybe so now we care about this side up
in front and then that side back there
but that's also going to cost six
dollars right so plus six dollars per
square meter and then there's two sides
and then what is it it's 2x times 5x to
the negative 2 so that's 10 right 2
times 5 is 10 x times X negative 2 X to
the negative 1 so let's simplify this so
we got we have the cost and there's no
room it said it was an open-top so
there's no there's no fabric we need for
the top so the cost of putting the
fabric or the material on this on this
open rectangle is C 20x squared plus
what's this 12 times 5 is 60 X to the
minus 1 plus let's see 12 times 10 120 X
to the minus 1 and so we can further
simplify that is 20x squared plus 180 X
to the minus 1 power and now we're ready
to just take the derivative and find out
what the minimum point is of this curve
so let's do that so C prime of X and
this is a fun non-hairy derivative so
it's 40 all right 2 times 20 X and then
minus 180 X to the minus 2 and we've the
minimum a maximum point are going to be
where this is equal to zero so let's set
that equal to zero let me clear up some
space let me clear up space I think you
understand all of this so let me let me
get rid of let me get rid of that
okay need that tool okay actually I
liked the drawing but it's got to go
because I need the room I need the room
if you review it just rewind the video
okay so we want to set the derivative to
find a minimum maximum point at minimum
or maximum point is the curve the slope
is zero so the derivative is zero so
let's figure that out so 40 X minus 180
X to the minus two is equal to zero and
the first thing I would do is just you
could divide both sides by you could
divide both sides by 20 and you get 2x
minus 9x minus 2 is equal to zero
divided by 20 to zero and then let's see
what you get if you add 9x to the -2 to
both sides you get 2x is equal to 9 X to
the minus 2 or 9 over x squared all
right that's the same thing as 9 X to
the minus 2 now I don't know let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
x squared and so you get 2x to the third
is equal to 9 or X to the third is equal
to 9 halves or X is equal to the cube
root or we could just say 9 halves to
the 1/3 power whatever that could be is
4.5 to the 1/3 power and do we know that
this is a minimum or a maximum point
well we could you know we could go and
take the second derivative and and then
you know confirm that we're concave
upwards at this point and then we would
know that we are at a minimum point and
this is the cheapest such container but
I'll tell you a little you know if you
see this and maybe you want to do you
want to prove that for yourself on a
test but an easy way to test that is
just try some other x right we have the
cost function right here try some other
X and you know that this is either going
to be a maximum or minimum or at least a
local maximum minimum and if you try
another accent if it
greater than you knows the minimum or
the other thing is well you know if
there's only one critical point they
asked you to find the cheapest container
that critical point is probably going to
be the minimum point but anyway so let's
just just for fun let's let's figure out
what that is what that is actually equal
to I'll actually go to Google Google
comm and let's see and we could just say
what we want nine-halves to the 1/3
power so that is 4.5 to the 1 to the 1 1
divided by 1/3 power
1 point 6 5 so that's our answer if X is
equal to one point six five so you know
plus some other points that we have the
cheapest container to produce so it's
1.65 something-something and there you
have it hopefully you found that vaguely
useful